hello everyone and welcome to part two
of the amazing battle that is the the
game between Wei and theil dubo this is
part two if you haven't seen part one do
check it out will be the first link in
the description below and only after
you've seen that can you watch this one
uh as I mean it's it's a part two video
uh so and to avoid any spoilers uh but
yeah in that video we defeated Daniel
duo with the black pieces in round two
of the global chess League now uh duo
will of course try to retaliate with the
black pieces himself this the game from
round seven uh so let's check it out we
now with the white pieces opens with
Pawn to D4 uh we have Pawn to D5 C4 E6
and now Knight to F3 so a standard um Tu
variation of the Queen's Pawn Knight to
F6 transposing into the Queen's gamb be
declined and now G3 we have Bishop to B4
with check uh going for the Catalin
Bishop to D2 and now Pawn to A5
transposing into the BOGO Indian uh we
have Bishop to G2 and now Castle with
Queen to C2 continuing development
nothing new here this has all been
played before Pawn to C5 striking in the
center and D captures on C5 and D4 so
white is up a pawn but it's a Double T
pawn and black has this very annoying um
Pawn on D4 so we e captures on B4 a
captures and he castles King side we
have Knight to C6 uh and Knight B to D2
We have Pawn to E5 and now Knight to G5
so uh putting pressure on that H7 Pawn
nothing U spectacular for the moment the
Knight is defending it it's a question
should you play H6 or not you know that
white will REM maneuver the Knight over
to E4 so for the moment dubo just goes
Queen to E7 and now there are a couple
moves that were played in this position
but we plays Bishop to D5 and it is now
as of move 13 that we have a completely
new game so he is of course inviting uh
dub of to capture on D5 but we all know
that results in Checkmate so uh you
can't move the Knight unless play H6 but
there's no reason to weaken your
position if you're not planning on
moving the knight from F6 so here Pawn
to G6 first now you can do whatever
there there's no more uh problems with
Queen captures on H7 and now Knight G to
E4 the Knight is also no longer needed
on G5 we have Bishop to F5 pinning the
Knight and now we captures on F6 as it
does come with check so Queen captures
and now Knight to E4 bringing another
Knight to E4 attacking the black queen
queen to E7 and now Pawn to A3 trying to
open up the A5 we have King to G7 by
Daniel unpinning from this um uh
diagonal also maybe uh with an idea of
either playing F6 at some point or maybe
in capturing it then playing Pawn to F5
uh many things become possible once the
king comes to G7 we have Bishop captures
and C6 uh B captures and now a captures
on B4 so okay giving up the strong
Bishop from D5 but grabbing yet another
Pawn H and now Rook 8 to B8 danil wants
to collect on B4 and Rook to a four so
what does Daniel have for the price of
two pawns now he has six pawns where he
still has all eight of his pawns well he
does have the center and he does have
sort of the weakened light squares
around the white king so maybe he can
use his bishop and the queen to do some
damage here or maybe move the bishop
Advance the pawn to F5 to F4 uh it is of
course possible so that is what he will
try to do but he tries it with Pawn to
H5 he wants to play Pawn to H4 and open
up um we's King side and while you're
probably expecting H4 from way he plays
Pawn to F3 he says okay you play H4 I'm
just going to advance my Pawn to G4 but
that's exactly what theil does he plays
H4 G4 and now he captures on e4 Bishop
captures on e4 Queen captures and now
Pawn to F5 this is how he opens up The
Path towards the white king G captures
on F5 G captures attacks the White Queen
and now Queen captures and C6 grabbing
yet another Pawn so now it's uh seven
pawns to four Pawns the the we is now up
three pawns and uh it's a very tricky
position objectively uh it's uh sort of
a drawish but only if you play it to to
absolute perfection and I will just show
you uh what that means that means that
if Rook F to C8 attacking the queen and
queen D5 you're going to repeat Rook to
d8 attack the queen and now uh you
either repeat moves or you go for Rook
to A7 attack the black queen now black
cannot capture on D5 because a queen
captures uh Queen will be captured with
check so Queen captures on A7 will be
played and now you just play Queen
captures on E5 so white will have to
sacrifice an entire Rook uh to continue
the attack here Queen captures on F5
King T8 and now Pawn to B5 and now the
the connected past pawns The Rook the
queen uh will be compensation enough for
the extra Rook so that's uh how the
position would go if played to absolute
perfection by both of them uh but this
is a rapid game of course and uh you
know the two of them are playing of
course that will not not happen uh Rook
to F6 Daniel goes after the white king
with Rook to F6 Queen to D5 and now Rook
to G6 with check we have King to H1 and
now uh there's this very very
interesting idea of Queen to G5 how does
white stop Queen to G5 just Queen G5 it
was not played in the game for a very
good reason but if Queen to G5 was
played how do you stop Checkmate feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only move for uh we on how to
prevent Checkmate and uh continue having
a better position while I give you a
couple of
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on being
an excellent Defender and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is Pawn to F4 or okay you can give one
check and then you have to play Pawn to
F4 but that's the idea you have to
defend the G2 uh Square you canot play
Rook to G1 of course and this is the
only thing you could do and it'd be
great for black if black could Advance
the pawn to E4
uh but the black queen is hanging so you
would have to do something about that
you would probably have to capture but
now just Queen captures on D4 with check
and after uh the king moves now play
Rook G1 as the queen also covers the G1
Square you take care of Checkmate you
force a queen trade and uh well you
pretty much have to trade everything
here otherwise you know you move the
queen also F4 Falls with check and it's
going to be uh Checkmate very soon so
after King to H1 danil figures out of
okay okay I can't play Queen to G5 right
away I will uh sort of improve with King
to H6 but now uh we have Rook to A8 now
way wants to trade off a pair of Rooks
we have Rook captures Queen captures and
now King back to H7 of course again you
can't really allow the queen to come to
h8 so King to H7 and now Pawn to F4 and
with this Pawn on F4 uh there's no way
to reach the white king and what's even
worse is that uh if the pawn remains on
F4 you don't even have Queen to G5 so E4
is played of course duo with down
material he doesn't want to uh mess up
his his Center maybe he can still play
D3 and create a pass Pawn but now Rook
to A1 and now uh how do you stop Rook to
A7 this will win the black queen Rook to
G7 is played and now Queen to D5 just
going for Queen captures on F5 with
check so queen queen to F6 and now Queen
to D6 offering a queen trade of course
dubov cannot accept a queen trade he
declines uh and now Queen captures on D4
and now we is up four point pawns so
that's I mean that's a lot and you can't
even go for Queen to G6 because again
Rook G1 the queen from D4 again guards
the G1 Square so after Queen captures on
D4 Queen to H5 was played going after
the E2 Pawn H but now Queen to E3 we
have Pawn to H3 still maybe some threats
are possible maybe if the Rook comes to
G2 uh we of course stops that Rook to G1
we have Rook to G4 and now comes a trade
Rook captures Queen captures you can't
capture with the pawn because then even
the E4 Pawn Falls with check so Queen
captures and G4 and now Queen G3 just
offering a trade and of course the queen
trade does not um go well for uh for uh
Daniel as he is down too much material
so he plays Queen H5 uh keeping an eye
on his pawns while also putting pressure
on that E2 pawn and now King to G1 now
we slowly starts improving the position
of his King uh we have Queen to
F7 and queen captures on H3 with check
King to G7 and now Pawn to C6 so now uh
there's nothing left for do of then to
maybe try and trick Wei somehow King to
G6 Queen to G3 check King to H7 Queen to
H4 check King to G6 now Queen to G5
check King H7 and pawn to C7 now forcing
the queen to move to start capturing
more material nothing much for dubov to
do here captures captures with check
King to H6 and now Queen to E6 with
check King H7 Queen captures an E4 with
check now uh we up six pawns not
something that you will hear very often
but yeah he's up six pawns King to H6
and now King to F2 and this is okay this
is resign time but as it is a team event
of course duo will still try to you know
be a little bit tricky maybe if you
somehow it's hard to say how but maybe
if the queen comes to
F7 and the pawn covers the G5 Square uh
okay maybe you can sacrifice the black
queen and it will be stalemate if such a
thing is possible but you know try
tricking way into that so Queen to B6
with check Pawn to C5 Queen to F6 and
now Pawn to F5 just marching forward
Queen captures on B2 okay you grab
another Pawn but Pawn to C6 you don't
need six pawns to win the game I mean
six extra pawns one one is sufficient so
King to H5 we have Pawn to H3 and now
King back to G5 otherwise Queen to G4 uh
followed by Queen to G6 will be
Checkmate so King to G5 now comes Pawn
to C7 and King to H6 just wasting time
trying to figure out how to how to uh
you know uh most uh easily get up some
sort of a some sort of a draw by
stalemate but of course he will not
allow it Queen to H4 check King to G7
Queen to G5 with check King to F7 and
queen to G6 and he was in this position
un move 57 that we that danil duo
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so King to E7 would
be played then something like Queen to
E6 check and that's it you go to f8 then
C8 Queen and after King moves either
Queen to G8 or maybe Queen to G6 will be
a Checkmate so which whichever you
prefer uh so yeah uh brilliant brilliant
stuff uh like I said if you haven't seen
the previous game do check it out first
link in the description below it is uh
really really a crazy game and it's uh
sort of an improvement on what was
played in the world CH championship
match between Yan pomnish and Magnus
Carlson not an improvement as way he
deviated with a with a line that's just
as great uh or maybe that he figured
that he knew how to play better than
danil dubo who was Magnus cross in
second for the world CH championship
match but yeah if you haven't seen it
first link in the description below it
will it will blow your mind and like I
said this is a two-part video so you
have to watch both parts uh so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
in this little Skirmish way takes both
wins against Duo but as usual if they if
the two of them ever play a game I will
definitely cover it and there is one
more game the first time they they met
up it was a classical game that they
played I will also show you that one
maybe tomorrow for for a nice Sunday a
classical game between we and dubove uh
yeah doesn't sound like a bad way to
spend the Sunday uh so really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Samuel
K Gart hlan Jeremy antios Carl Weinberg
and David gasparian for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your
day